mucho se ha hablado del techo de deuda
pero explíquenos por favor qué es esto y
cómo funciona
saludos y verán el techo de deuda de los
eeuu es algo tan americano como el patio
de manzana es un debate anual desde los
últimos 10 años diría donde llegan a la
conclusión si quieren fundar el gobierno
americano en seguir montando la deuda
que ha acumulado el país que ya tocan
los 26.7 trillones de dólares
y nuevamente llegamos a este a esta
lucha no al hilo y los partidos negocian
para subir el techo porque el techo de
la deuda se convierte en un mecanismo
político
se convierte un mecanismo político
porque implícitamente el gobierno anda
utilizando deuda deuda internacional
deuda doméstica vía los bonos que venden
al mercado de capitales y lo necesitan
para fundar el gobierno el 70 por ciento
de los gastos del gobierno americano se
fondean con esta deuda el resto se funde
había los impuestos entonces es una
necesidad entonces ambos partidos
necesitan que esta dinámica fluye sin
sin interrupción y utiliza en el debate
de acumular más deuda o no como un
evento político para transmitir su
mensaje y de echarle un poco la culpa a
un partido al otro pero todos los
senadores y los miembros del congreso
quieren su trabajo quieren que el
gobierno sigue andando y no hay
alternativas fuera de fundar el gobierno
y subir el techo de deuda mientras
continúa este esta discusión sobre el
techo de deuda también surgen dudas
sobre por qué no se elimina
definitivamente que cree usted
miraremos hemos entrado a una dinámica
del gobierno americano nueva desde la
administración de clinton el gobierno de
los eeuu ha decidió correr deuda para
fundar el gobierno y no han no han
cambiado de métodos y a la misma vez
representa un producto financiero
bastante atractivo para el resto del
mundo de ningún bono con rendimientos
positivos los bonos europeos rinden
tasas negativas y a la misma vez es de
un gobierno sólido con reputación y poca
probabilidad del default o es decir no
pagarle de vuelta a la deuda de los
inversores entonces es un mecanismo que
funciona fundida el gobierno americano
produce un producto financiero para el
resto del mundo y con esa dinámica se
han creado empresas espectaculares
enormes ha crecido la economía
rápidamente y sigue andando de esas de
esa manera entonces hoy en día es una
cuestión si el gobierno de los eeuu está
depende demasiado de esta dinámica y si
eventualmente puede causar problemas
económicos sociales políticos
otra de las grandes preguntas que ha
surgido es cuál va a ser el escenario
más probable en diciembre cuando tengan
que volver a discutir sobre este tema
muy rápidamente que cree usted si lo más
probable es que simplemente suban el
techo de vuelta la pregunta es si lo van
a subir por un monto fijo como han hecho
en esta última ronda de negociaciones
han subido el monto a un nivel fijo para
analizarlo en diciembre la pregunta de
si van a hacer lo mismo o si van a
introducir una dinámica nueva para
fundir el gobierno es perpetuamente